[Musique]
bonjour je suis michel marc bouchard
je suis écrivain et je suis originaire
du lac-saint-jean
je suis né sur la ferme familiale mais
qui était également un abattoir d'une
famille quand même assez nombreuses
parce que ma grand mère en est à son
troisième mariage qui peut dire qu'on
était submergé donc de retarder de
plusieurs de cuisine qui fait que ça ton
une communauté je pense que la terre
autour de 25 enfants choses comme ça
tous les jeunes dans cette famille
nombreuse s'animait par la conversation
et par son côté avec ce qu'on avait à
dire à raconter alors le meilleur
compteur se le dire l'emportait celui
qui est le plus drôle emportait et j'ai
l'impression que moi aussi j'avais envie
de monter sur la chaise produire pour
raconter quelque chose
ce qui veut dire que cette tradition de
conteur et la notion du temps de
raconter une histoire
vié de la est encore maintenant
extrêmement présente de mon travail
pour moi la famille c'est la première
identité c'est premier regard de l'autre
ce qui veut dire que c'est un endroit
extrêmement déterminé je pense qu'on
question c'est un principe extrêmement à
st
un acte de liberté de devoir la manic
quitté la famille on doit aller se
construit nos mains on doit quelque part
vivre quelque chose en dehors du cercle
familial et je pense que ça fait de
meilleurs individus de meilleurs parents
mais aux adultes et par le fait même
lorsqu'on revue je pense que montpellier
deux meilleures amies avec l'ensemble
les fameux la valeur familiale la plus
positive c'est que même si on s'est pas
vu depuis très longtemps
en l'espace de trois secondes en une
famille dans une famille on peut se dire
on peut vivre des émotions d'une grande
extrémités et deux secondes après un
retour dans un quotidien confortable à
l'animé ce qui fait je trouve que là ça
me plus conçu le 10 mai la familiarité
de la famille et sa plus grande qualité
[Musique]